what do you think about the giant
ecosystem
of frameworks uh in javascript it feels
like
because i mean this is a side effect of
how many people use javascript
a lot of entrepreneurial spirit like
create their own javascript
uh uh frameworks yep and they're
actually awesome uh in our own different
ways
and that this is an interesting question
about almost like
philosophically about biological system
and evolution all that kind of stuff
do you see that as good or should it
like should some of them die out quicker
i think that maybe they should now
jquery was a very clever
thing john resumed this library that was
sort of query and do
and blended sort of css selector syntax
with
javascript sort of object graph or dom
querying and made it very easy for
people to do things almost like they
were learning jquery as its own language
yes domain-specific language
and uh that i think reflected in part
the
difficulty of using the document object
model these apis that were originally
designed in the 90s for java as well as
javascript they're very
object-oriented or even procedural
they're very kind of verbose
and it took like a constructor call on
three different you know
hokey pokey dances to do something
whereas in jquery it's just one line
right so that fed back finally into the
standards
didn't it didn't mean we standardized
jquery it wasn't quite that concise but
you find now with the modern standards
that we were working on
in the html5 sort of um effort
that things became simpler the fetch api
and the query selector api
document.queryselector
a lot of things can be done now in raw
javascript that you would
make more concise interests in jquery
but it's it's not bad it's it's pretty
good whereas in the old dom of
15 years ago it was just too promote so
maybe the frameworks were born
kind of uh because javascript lacks some
of the features of
jquery and so like uh now that
javascript is
swallowing what jquery was then the
frameworks will
only the ones that truly add value will
stick around and the other ones will die
out and that highlights this also this
division between the core language
javascript which can show up in other
places like node.js on the server side
and the browser-specific apis or the
document object model apis
which are even managed by the w3c the
standards body
that was off in xml la la land when we
were doing real javascript standards in
ecma
and you you you have this division of
labor division of responsibility and
division of style and sort of aesthetics
and also speed so the document object
model really stagnated
after um microsoft kind of
de-invested in the web and microsoft did
something in their haste in the spirit
of netscape doing things quickly and
getting on first
called dhtml and some of their
innovations that were like an
alternative document object model
didn't really get standardized until
html5 when
we pragmatists said opera at the time uh
ian hickson who went to google
apple and mozilla said let's let's
xml is not going to replace html html4
is too old
let's standardize html5 based on all
this good stuff including that dhtml
variant
you